foreign
[Music]
I said welcome to the creek of the cave
at this time he has an internal wall
cell phones please keep table talk to a
minimum and refrain from heckling the
performers now I am proud to present
your host for the evening please put
your hands together for the very funny
Mr Hans Kim
thank you it's good to be here in Austin
Texas to watch some people date
my name is Hans Kim and tonight you will
be getting some dating advice from one
of the
biggest nerds in the world me [ __ ]
loser like what am I going to tell you
right but it's gonna be fun we're gonna
all laugh at each other and at me and uh
at the other people dating you know it
should be fun uh if you haven't been to
the show before it's a dating show so
get your dating pants on and get ready
to ask people what they like to do for
fun because that's pretty much how you
date nowadays
are you guys ready to date
[Music]
okay well we're gonna do it anyways uh
we have a wonderful guest tonight A
comedic Superstar a talent of wunderkind
he is not German uh maybe he is but he's
very funny very Stout uh very funny guy
he also snores a lot get up for Ike
Rafferty human comedy machine
[Applause]
here he is
Ike the Thai Rafferty
hello Hans hello Ike uh I was going to
say you know you're too hard on yourself
and then I heard all the [ __ ] you said
about me so oh [ __ ] we got the angry Ike
tonight I'm good I'm calm it's good
let's date I'm excited okay I'm ready
that's a good energy for dating oh yeah
uh so far we have no straight woman
signed up let's just straight man Story
of My Life
so uh we might have to go hunting
tonight for some straight women oh
here's one
your Florence Nightingale
look at her so bravely putting her name
in hopefully it's her name well no if
it's not
uh we're gonna watch her date a random
man in a bucket
please do not call the cops
this is all according to plan
which woman will it be
I don't know who to pick okay let's see
anytime during the show ladies just
coming up here and sign on up we got RJ
Marchand RJ
get get the hell up here RJ RJ here he
comes
two arms and a cast oh hell yeah you
need love more than anyone else buddy
he is pulling his own chair I hope you
got it okay ladies he's not gonna be
pulling your chair out he can barely do
it himself for his own chair oh there he
goes with his feet he'll give you a foot
job very dexterous
impressive impressive uh are you excited
RJ to meet the possible love of your
life absolutely yeah Now's the Time now
now is the time seize the now okay here
we go
it could be anybody
except it's not it's Michaela Michaela
Michaela
get the hell oh she didn't sign herself
signed up her friend wow classic move
that just guarantees that you will be up
next whatever your name is Michaela's
friend
oh well I'm assuming you're Michaela
okay do you consent to this or has this
been thrust upon you
hey everybody she consents to having it
thrust upon her give it up for RJ
Marchand and Michaela hi give it up
all right
hello Hi how are you is your mic on
okay I'm gonna figure that out in a
moment
uh double shoulder dislocation yeah yeah
you do uh I uh I was 30 seconds into a
soccer game and I I fell uh went double
Palms down and they both popped out hey
yeah at least you know you were doing
something fun and it's a cool story so I
feel cool you know yeah I feel very cool
right now for sure yeah do you have to
be uh it's six weeks till I did the
X-ray and the MRI there's nothing I can
do about it other than just rest and eat
and sleep yeah that sounds like a good
you know yeah having to ask your 24 year
old roommate to take your shirt off for
you yeah like nothing better than that
you know yeah
I was hoping I would see him naked first
you know you win something you lose yeah
or you lose and then you lose again so
yeah
[Music]
30. 30. yep okay I turned 24 tomorrow I
didn't ask
okay the state's over actually
and time get up for RJ marchan and the
very young very lovely Michaela hello
wow RJ good job getting her age that's
an expert move yeah yeah
[Music]
hurt you know I'm not yeah see well wait
till you get a load of RJ marchan
RJ you injured your arms in a game of
soccer that's very hard to do yeah yeah
famously an armless game yeah well you
know it's like winning a really shitty
Lottery it just happened you know yeah
you won the lottery called you don't
have to play soccer again
you're still in soccer shape yeah you
can still kick about right
where were you playing soccer at uh the
uh the indoor soccer league off of uh
manchacha
hell yeah I'm in Chacha that's right am
I saying you're right uh Cha-Cha
that's cool minchaka
you tell me where are you from RJ
Alabama Alabama
how do you feel about down south boys
Michaela you know I am from the south so
yeah I love a good Southern man we're
from I'm from
cool very cool yeah it's a group
nice Fort Worth yeah nice that's nice
yes I'm not from Texas but I'm assuming
that's nice the fort and it's worth it's
a good spot worth it yeah so uh how has
your dating life been in Fort Worth well
um I grew up there and I went to college
in Arizona I just moved here to Austin
in February so escape the past I get it
yeah
starting a new life there we go who
better to start it with than the future
that a guy with no arms from Alabama
yeah
yeah he's uh very very harmless right
now
you know there could be something very
magical here if you're willing to make
an investment are you willing Michaela
to pay for his x-rays
you know
um I think I might yeah
wow this this first day is going well
we could have had Bernie Sanders and
this wouldn't have been a problem you
know but that dream died in South
Carolina where a lot of dreams die so
was that a reference to the Democratic
primaries yeah okay very timely in that
2020 yeah yeah wow uh Bernie Sanders
supporter from Alabama yeah that's about
as rare as a man that injured both his
arms
he's one in a million you better snatch
him up oh my God
so Michaela uh have you ever dated a
white man before
I have actually yeah and how did it go
thank you thank you thank you they need
all the help they can get you're welcome
a challenge
that's okay well in what way yeah oh I
mean not the fact that he was white that
wasn't the challenge
tweet
[Laughter]
still in the game RJ yeah
what was the challenge
oh
where do we start I mean I mean we're
not going to get into that it was just a
lot you know well it might be good for
RJ to know what maybe his worst
characteristic was so he knows what to
avoid your friend popped up on that one
so it seems like there was something
going on there right
um what was it
this is more like a second
thank God he didn't lose his hair in
that soccer game oh man
it's my second date
it's not the first day yeah there we go
oh well do you want to sign up again
as bad as this looks probably the best
one you could have pulled
[Laughter]
how you signed up RJ but you did you
wrote your name legendary yeah very
inspiring RJ how big is your penis uh
like between six and a half and seven
holy [ __ ] so six and a half
[Laughter]
yeah depending on what movie's on you
know that's soft to hard wow yeah those
are good numbers those are good numbers
is the dangler
gonna get it caught on some tripwire
so uh yeah you uh you're like the Pete
Davidson you got a very dreamy look
about you RJ uh what date am I on right
now
you sign up for the straight box
uh you guys should get a minute I don't
know
yeah I'm gonna need less than a minute
with RJ
I'm gonna get an anal orgasm very
quickly with his six and a half inch
[ __ ] in my ass anyways it's only gonna
be soft in your ass you think you don't
think it's gonna get hard away here okay
all right uh RJ what's your dating life
what's your dating history like uh I've
been single for like two months
something like that now oh two whole
months oh yeah poor RJ now your arms are
broken yeah I'm getting what I deserve
you know the move to Austin's going
great so there we go this is what
following your dreams looks like
everybody was it your fault or her fault
that you're broke up no it was just you
know good question it was just time uh
we made each other better we made each
other funnier and happier but you know
we started like running into the same
problems over and over again so how much
damage can you do huh uh what race was
she she was a Jewish white you know
um
a little stingy with the money no not at
all okay it was uh what would you say is
something that maybe you could have
improved in that relationship that you
would do better with on your next
relationship with uh
uh good question I haven't thought about
that maybe if I did I wouldn't have
broke my arms you know yeah um do you
have anything to talk about besides your
broken arms dude like this is getting
I'm getting bored yeah why am I leading
with that you know uh
I don't know probably just being a more
receptive more mature more receptive
that type of thing yeah
how would you be more mature to Michaela
uh
you could do your minute over which you
can't what would you do I would have
asked you your age yeah that seems like
a pretty
sure yeah
the little things yeah I I clearly I
always learn after so you know if we
hadn't have said your name he wouldn't
have asked
wow for some reason I'm just selfish
right now I don't know why hopefully
you're not selfish in other ways uh I
can't be anymore you know
oh yeah
yeah I think you're gonna be on top
Michaela
yeah
I'm not gonna have a choice
no his arms are already broken
yeah
um yeah so
um RJ what's uh what's your ideal date
what would you do ideally mini golf
paddle board tennis baseball uh
Lazy Dog yeah uh I don't know uh just
like
dinner movie pretty pretty basic pretty
vanilla just anything that like allows
you a time to get to know the person
that type of thing have you ever done
dinner or movies anything like that are
you doing a dinner I'm not a dinner and
a movie you hate eating and looking at
things yes okay well actually
um yeah no I think that's not like a
good
date maybe that's why what's your ideal
date
outside okay probably like an activity
where you do something together because
I feel like you learn more about a
person when you're actually doing
something like tug of war or something
like that yeah I think that'll go great
for you actually
well that's great because I believe we
have a rope set up Jimmy bring it out
uh alternately I have a question for you
so you weren't and hey I respect it you
weren't willing to go into that kind of
second date talking points so what was
the worst first date you've ever had oh
my goodness
so again RJ know what to avoid so it was
actually after my first relationship
ended I was a freshman in college and I
decided to hit the apps and I matched
with this guy who was a gold medalist
for the Olympics but
um [ __ ]
fell to tell me that it was the Special
Olympics
Michael Phelps
um so I mean you know no hate no shade
to the Special Olympics great but um I
think that that was important that's the
quote of the episode right here
[Music]
to know before RJ you could sign up for
the Special Olympics yeah oh my God I
believe we have a special bucket right
can he sign up for that yeah that you
could be in the lgbtqia plus bucket as a
man with no arms you gotta take whatever
people come to
um yeah that's cool he was in the
Special Olympics oh my gosh that's such
a letdown you know and I just had I had
to pull through I had to see it through
you know and so I because I didn't want
to be mean of course you know he was
still a really nice person
but yeah
what please stop actually did you say
what was he missing yeah
is it missing anything
a limb a chromosome nothing oh wow lucky
guy then so he was just Clowning on
Special Needs people
he was like an RJ he was uh yeah
interested and talk [ __ ] get hit you
know so there was nothing wrong with him
and he was in a special I'm not going to
go into his medical concerns you know
that's fair yeah
well we went into RJ's medical concerns
pretty heavily yeah I thought nope we
had to was it something okay so it's
something he can hide all right good
we're getting closer tell us when we're
getting warm okay
AIDS
people with AIDS in the Special Olympics
because I got a weak immune system you
can cough on him and defeat him in
combat
what do you do for work
a bartender okay yeah awesome yeah I
K State gig
so now I bartend full time
yeah nice you're getting people drunk
yeah it's my favorite pastime I love to
do it why didn't you like commercial
real estate
um so in my office I was the youngest
person there by like 20 years so
it's like difficult to have like a lot
of clients that were older than me and I
feel like I wasn't respected a lot so
um I just decided to leave be somewhere
that I was happy
yeah what are your thoughts on the
terminology of master bedroom versus
primary bedroom always master bedroom
hey you heard it real estate expert
right here not a lot of master bedrooms
and Commercial Real Estate it's okay
that's true it's okay I obliged you
that's fine that's a shame honestly
unless you're getting commercial real
estate for Harvey Weinstein
well that's cool RJ what do you do for
work uh I'm between jobs right now I
just moved I wonder why yeah yeah I I
I've just moved here haven't been able
to find something that's suitable to my
needs yet um your special needs yeah I
uh I manage uh two or three small
businesses throughout the last five
years before I moved here okay yeah yeah
that sounds really good what kind of
businesses
mostly no uh mostly uh recently it was a
ax throwing shop believe it or not yeah
no way yeah okay yeah that is the
whitest thing you've ever said and the
uh the other one was uh was a poke place
so and that's the second whitest thing
you've ever said yeah
so you just go on Craigslist and just
apply for everything no I just you know
I was trying to just find jobs that
freed me up to do stand-up at night so
those were the ones that oh you're a
comic yeah that's awesome
do you
like comedy Michaela I love comedy do
you find RJ funny
yeah the right way yeah
you did you're not boring I mean look at
those arms
he's a very comedic injury you even hurt
yourself in a funny way yeah so what uh
what do you think you're gonna do uh
after you get your arms fixed what's the
first thing that you're gonna do uh put
on a shirt by myself uh be able to
shower by myself shave more efficiently
I think your roommate will be really sad
about that yeah
I can't wait for my arms to be back to
fully functional yeah
you know closer together with any
roommate or Aid or anyone at all in your
life no it's made me more self-reliant
believe it or not oh yeah
hurt your arms you'll become more
independent
have you ever injured yourself
catastrophically like RJ has I did I did
actually last year on Valentine's Day I
broke my foot tripping over my o2v
um
I thought you were gonna say you tripped
Head Over Heels over some lover on
Valentine's Day but you felt that would
have been a better story I actually did
tell that story a few times because the
first one is embarrassing
Cupid shot you and that is embarrassing
as dating someone who is in the Special
Olympics
burn not very many people get that story
okay where were you when this happened I
was in my I was in my dorm room and um
my best friend we were roommates and
after I kicked him out I hysterically
cried and everyone on my floor basically
left but not too many witnesses this
wasn't how like a Jamba Juice or
anything no problem it was in my dorm
room
that's good yeah you'll probably hear
you're crying as you waited for the
elevator oh
hold on to that Pride you know yeah you
know well this brings up a good question
then how many dates uh do you have to go
on before you're willing to let your
partner see you cry oh
maybe the first one yeah okay great
on the first day right here right now
I'll do it yes uh watching The Notebook
Marley and Me Oh Manchester by the Sea
that'll do it to you yeah
cars
specifically cars 3.
RJ have you ever cried in a movie yeah
totally yeah which one uh Manchester by
the Sea yeah just said it yeah any any
Casey Affleck movie uh I think the first
one was like you know where the Red Fern
Grows all the other stuff like that Bama
stuff you know yeah I mean the books or
the movies uh the movies we can't read
back home so yeah
books on tape right that's awesome
you're a sensitive soul
what uh what brought you out of Alabama
uh stand up you know okay you were doing
stand up in Alabama driving a lot for
stand up you know like he can stand up
that's a rarity in these parts yeah he
can talk you know how do you get around
now uh uh by car how do you get around I
mean but I mean do you do you I mean
what is it the right is functional
enough for me to take it off and then
and then use oh so this is just for show
yeah yeah I enjoy this [ __ ] you dude
what the [ __ ]
but using the left knee right the steer
you know basically I gotta see that that
sounds awesome basically I'm like you
know just like every drunk driver in
Austin right now I'm hoping to get
pulled over at some point so I hope so
too so I can explain this to a cop yeah
I hope so too yeah are you drunk no but
I'm [ __ ] up
well luckily you have a car and you're
not going to be stopped by not having
arms to drive it what uh what's the
closest you've been to an accident
uh in a car like pissing yourself or
anything like that uh as far as the car
is concerned I got cut off once when I
was uh 19 and totaled my Corolla that
was that was pretty nasty yeah hit a
guardrail head on
it's too bad it's a normal day for an
Asian person
that's cool so uh did you get uh money
from it no no he sped off and um and you
know I just had to take it you know
you know
Tiny Tim had no arms everybody Jesus
Christ
Michaela yeah where's the Christmas
carol crowd you [ __ ] [ __ ] don't know
Christmas Carol come on
he had arms I think he had a crush
so yeah Michaela what do you think about
uh a second date what would you take uh
RJ maybe in a hospital or rehab facility
something like that why would you both
yeah where are we at on those x-rays you
still willing to do that
I mean he did tell me he was a seven
incher I might do it
okay don't need an x-ray for that huh
yeah
I'm kidding RJ where do you think that
with your two months of knowledge of
Austin where would you uh take Michaela
on a second date uh you would have to
tell me I'm still learning my way around
I I you know you said the park so I
haven't been to Zilker yet is that how
you say it how do you say the parks yeah
you got it yeah he's okay that would be
one yeah yeah Zilker Park yeah I haven't
seen the that's yeah I really want to
see the bats there's like a bat show
like you watch the bats at night like
you leave a bat show yeah like you like
stand on the bridge and like watch like
thousands you know anybody here seen the
bat show
okay oh some claps for the bats all
right that's cool hard up for live
entertainment in Austin okay
okay are you willing to see Bats or yeah
let's go let's go catch Cove and check
out some bats I don't think you can make
those jokes dude yeah
you can't ride a bird scooter
can't fly like the bats you know Camp
paddle board yeah a lot of limits here
um yeah that's cool so uh yeah what do
you uh what do you think about Austin so
far it's awesome it's fun yeah yeah you
know can't wait to get my arms back and
be able to do normal [ __ ] again yeah
that's what they say about Austin it's
better with arms yeah it's a real a city
for the armed both ways yeah
um but yeah don't uh worry about RJ you
can't pull a gun on you uh he's a
harmless little boy I don't know we saw
how dexterous his feet were earlier
maybe he whips one out with his uh I
don't know maybe yeah the disabled are
just as uh capable of violence as the
able we shouldn't discriminate based on
ability I have two dislocated arms
they're not [ __ ]
that's like the first word they learned
there
technically he is [ __ ] he is from
Alabama it comes with the territory but
give it up for RJ and Michaela they went
on a date I don't know I think I smell
some Sparks or some love in the side I
smell love what's your friend's name
Nicole you signed up your friend now
it's your turn to come up give it up for
Nicole this is karma get the hell up
here coming on up Nicole Nick Cole get
up here
lucky man coming up
dating a person who signs up her friends
to find uh a date Patrick Carpenter oof
good luck Patrick here he comes Patrick
Carpenter with a cowboy hat a real Texan
yeah come on you don't have to be
jealous because you can't find love
these people
they might be soul mates hello hello
that's part of the fun you got to figure
it out Patrick Carpenter and Nicole one
minute starting now
hi hey what's up
so what's your name again Nicole Nicole
it's still Nicole
word I'm Patrick
cool from uh from Boston from Boston how
about you California oh we're in
California uh Northern California
like San Francisco or like pretty close
to San Francisco yeah
I've been in Texas for
three months now oh word so newbie trans
uh transport but nice
I'm just here for the weekend I'm going
to be moving out here in June
why are you moving here
in here stand up
I know sensing sensing a trend
cool cool yeah you're doing great so far
you as well
y'all doing great on the leading
questions too thank you
so why'd you sign up your friend uh
because her birthday's tomorrow so we're
out for her birthday and time we got up
for Nicole and
Patrick Carpenter
Patrick you're you're you've been here
you're just visiting and you already
have a cowboy hat
how badly do you want to move to Texas
um pretty bad uh
I I just I got this uh because I was
watching Yellowstone I was like binging
it and I was like those hats look pretty
cool so I I got one
man I can't remember the last time I was
watching a good show and I thought I
gotta get one of those hats that's uh
wow yeah it just it had that effect on
me and I was thinking like I go to
school in western Mass at uh UMass and
like no one on campus has a cowboy hat
and I'm like I could be the first one
and I did well no one's wearing Kilts
either maybe you could I did people
started wearing them after that so hell
yeah be different you know you're in
Texas that's awesome you're doing it uh
Nicole have you ever been on a date with
a guy that was wearing a cowboy hat
before
too many
[Music]
can we see what it looks like without
the cowboy hat yeah of course
look at those luscious locks
like Fabio over here [ __ ] yeah
can you do a little no yeah just like
that's all you got haircuts because like
I figured that my weed budget could be a
little bit more if I just like have
longer hair weed or haircuts okay it's
not a hard decision to make got it I can
see why you have that hat on you're a
ginger you're very sensitive to the sun
yeah
Nicole uh uh how's your uh David how's
uh how's your day with your girlfriend's
been so far it's
okay you guys decided to come down to
Austin to well she's in Austin so I mean
we have to come to her okay so we're
just starting our night and do you
normally like to [ __ ] over your friends
like that absolutely specifically you
ever push someone in front of a bus I
would her but
Michaela there's a reason it's her
birthday let's get her murdered
in front of a bus yeah
oh [ __ ] can you do any tricks bro that's
sick
put it on the table and do a tornado
right now right [ __ ] now let's go
where's the you're just blowing it in
her face this date's going great
lucky Nicole yeah
do you ever Vape
long time ago a long time ago okay
dark history there or uh what's going on
it's called College okay are you in
college right now yeah I'm a senior that
makes sense then that makes sense okay
all right are you okay with a little bit
of an age difference or well I'm 25. oh
oh
got a got a Van Wilder over here yeah
you must be from Alabama if you know
what I mean
he's [ __ ]
what are you in college for
communication oh yeah I know why because
like they didn't have a film major when
I started and then like
I just I didn't want to change it so uh
well let's not laugh or dog him too much
I will I took some notes and I will say
compared to the date of Michaela and RJ
he got into it he found out her name uh
she was very vague about her hometown
for some reason and he respected that he
didn't pry too much what's going on with
your hometown no one knows Northern
California everybody knows Southern
College I think we would maybe be able
to retain a city name if you could spit
one out at us Pleasanton oh yeah you
should have said nothing okay
Pleasanton the Bay Area is close enough
to where that works for people so so Bay
Area
but instead you said Northern California
it's in Northern California one of the
bigger states in the Union
it's the north of that it's 50 percent
of one of the biggest states that's cool
California is a cool place uh have you
ever been to California yeah it's pretty
fun and what hat were you wearing when
you went there
um
like a a Bruins hat I was uh going to
see a fish show
the first show so you yeah Bruins
Bruins what is the Bruin is that the
baseball team Bruins is hockey yeah oh
we don't say other things you have in
common this is exciting okay
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] I thought we were getting somewhere
there
like I don't really watch it that much I
just kind of like wear the hat because
like it's a cool hat it is a good hat
are there a lot of hats in hockey
um not enough I gotta Shield your eyes
from the harsh sun when you're playing
ice hockey well the glare on the ice you
know it can be uh a lot a bottom hat
it's just under your chin or helmet
that's also what they wear
whoa that's a touchy subject how do you
feel about special needs people you ever
date a special needs uh athlete I feel
cornered you're about to
I don't have the experience that she
does so I can't say personally but I
don't think I have a problem
don't think you have a problem wow I
have opinions what a heart of gold
it's a lack of experience
what are you experienced with who are
the people that you normally date what's
your type cowboy
s Cowboys Patrick Carpenter Cowboys are
kind of [ __ ] right
right in their own special way they're
countarded they've been hanging out with
cows too much well unfortunately Patrick
is not a cowboy he just wears a hat uh
where are you where are you meeting
Cowboys at you like Southern Boys
um I haven't met too many Southern Boys
but we both went to a college in Arizona
and there's Arizona Cowboys so you get
what you get I think those are called
meth addicts
some of them
without them well hold on now maybe
Patrick can rise to the occasion what's
the manliest most cowboy thing you've
ever done you ever milk a steed what
have you done no pressure you know milk
a steed okay
I think that's the smelliest thing I've
ever done it's called jerking off a cow
okay have you ever done that Patrick you
ever jerked off a cow because that's
pretty manly if you ask I can't say that
I have but uh I do buy a lot of milk
from CVS so uh
CVS milk that is dangerous as [ __ ] yeah
called out CVS that's so that's how you
get covet is drinking CVS milk
why do you go to CVS for your milk do
you go to it's because like I live off
campus and uh I take the bus because I
don't have a car and uh CBS is just the
easiest place to go do you have a car I
have a truck
hey is there room for two in that truck
there
there's not room for two in your truck
like I'm willing to ride in the back you
know like anything yeah pop this bad boy
in the bed and you guys got yourself a
match already talking about anal
uh Patrick so you uh what's the manliest
thing you've done besides buy milk at
CVS
um
no pressure
what's the the most feminine thing
you've ever done maybe this will come to
your mind quicker
uh watch the movie Magnolia probably
like once a month and uh Cry by myself
[Music]
you've got a lot of time to kill on your
hands that's a very long movie okay all
right it's a sensitive Soul he feels a
lot
uh why are you in college at 25 did you
uh perhaps join the military
I just uh I didn't want to join the
military uh I kept believing the
recruiter messages on read
oh yeah [ __ ] the government I didn't
want to become a ghost at the Uncle Sam
yeah he wanted to know what it felt like
to do that to someone
being from Boston like a lot of my
friends are like becoming townies and uh
I just like I don't know I was like
I don't want to work construction or do
landscaping for the rest of my life so
should probably uh go to college
construction is mainly
yeah yeah we got a construction worker
in the crowd
no okay all right good good
those guys freaked me out
so you didn't want to do the manly
construction job so you're like let me
go to a feminine school and also I had
this I had this weird idea that it'd be
easier to get laid at College
it's kind of like the same thing with
you getting into comedy uh but it didn't
really work out as well yeah a lot of
dudes in comedy
a lot of dudes you should just switch to
dudes it might be so much easier I don't
know
we got a gay bucket I think if you want
to sign up
Nicole how was college for you what
college did you go to uh Northern
Arizona University
uh nursing oh word yeah I'm an ER nurse
oh nice wow
thank you for your service
thanks I thought he was gonna be the one
I was saying that to but that's cool
you're a nurse uh have you ever had
treated any Cowboys
a lot more of the meth ones the mess the
meth boys
I don't get the the other ones in my ER
too often they tend to take care of
themselves so yeah it's only [ __ ] go
to the ER
fix yourself up
what's the craziest uh thing has anyone
ever tried to date you inside of the ER
like they're coughing up a lung and
they're like by the way I'm single
um I'm pretty sure I might be in two
people's Wills I'm just waiting on you
know a call back let's see if things so
I'm still working with that you're
playing the long game yep that's cool
how did you get into their Wills
that'll do it
put a little uh bully into their little
hair flip a little you're all better so
you can go home now
I think you're in my well right now
I just got into my will uh that's cool
you're a nurse that's awesome uh Patrick
you have any questions any uh you have
any lumps on you you want to check out
or anything off duty
no I'm uh I'm pretty healthy other than
uh Hey if you asked him to communicate
with you I'm sure he'd be willing to do
it even though he's not in school right
now struggling right now I did wipe on a
bird scooter yesterday so um you did
what now on a bird scooter I wiped out
on it poor baby I hit the vape pen a bit
too many times poor baby while you were
burning while you were scootering no it
was before but uh I I thought it would
be a good idea to go down a hill on uh
full speed really not a good idea I
wouldn't recommend it
wow and you still have both your arms
fully functional yeah I'm not a T-Rex
RJ you're a [ __ ]
you think wiping out on a bird scooter
is dangerous try playing soccer
for the Daredevils out there
uh Nicole any uh any any words of advice
for Patrick any words of encouragement
words of affirmation ooh that's sad
we've switched from possible lovers to
now oh do you have any
anything you want to add a boys you want
to hang them
move off campus
um yeah go move near and Whole Foods or
an HEB
better milk there yeah but
try milking a steed no I'm saying I'm
just saying I don't recommend that
actually actually some of that sweet
Steed milk don't knock it till you try
it Nicole don't knock it till you try it
those are the people that
people okay and I milk his teeth all
right
that's how you become manly and strong
drinking bull semen
uh Patrick any anything that you'd like
to say to Nicole
want to grab a drink after this or
something taco truck
um I have two dates with me [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] does that mean your friends
should have signed up for the lgbtqia
plus bucket
can we put our name in twice
you didn't put your name in at all
that's a very good point why am I here
because you signed your friend yeah this
is karma we said it at the beginning
it's karma how does it feel this is
karma don't do bad
well that's good all right that's what
we like to hear uh Patrick thank you for
coming on the show thank you for going
on a real live date
word
hope there's a CVS on your way home can
I get one last Cloud on your way out one
last one last big puff uh it's our oh
do a tornado dude do a tornado you
didn't do it before not into the mic
okay get out of here bro that was some
acoustic vaping right there
let's see what we have in the lgbtqia
plus bucket
hopefully an asexual I'm very excited
we got Lexi
former contestant Lexi coming up woo
yeah we got some Lexi fans in the house
okay I think this was from last week she
kept her name is she dating herself
what's happening
she's already dated herself okay she
doesn't need us anymore she's found
Nirvana oh my God
we got a man coming up and can we get
some white lights up here on the side
let's just light this place up like a
Christmas tree we got Drew craigle
and Liz or what was the other person
Julia let's see Lexi is next year that's
it
uh we got
Michaela s
Michaela s
here she comes oh no always a good way
to start out a date she does not want to
go on this date oh no
it's always the start of a good date
it's a no
here we go
here she comes one of three people in
the woman bucket yeah of course you're
gonna get called give it up for Michaela
s and her date hell yeah the guy oh man
Drew kragel
whoa nice to meet you sweetheart nice to
meet you too
are we starting yeah don't look at me
look at him unless you want to date me
it's fine that's fine how have you been
doing
um I'm doing good today how are you yeah
no major complaints yeah what you've
been up to
um I went for a 5K run this morning in a
2K walk that sounds exhausting it is did
you do anything like mildly enjoyable oh
it was really enjoyable I like to like
do that stuff
not to spoil it I don't think we're
gonna get along it's okay it's okay
what did you do today
I woke up at about noon uh
massive hangover uh brought three beers
into the bathtub and sounds like my type
of guy yeah so that that seemed to heal
it up just nice and fine
new Apple watch there though that looks
nice yeah
um I work out way too much to like not
have an Apple Watch Fair time give it up
for Drew kragel and Michaela s
they want on the least charismatic date
I've ever seen
ow you said I don't think we're gonna
get along in the middle of the date
she's gonna make me run I think they
both displayed some very ugly traits I
mean you're bragging non-stop you are
like breaking hearts halfway through
this is this is Bonkers
uh Drew kragel you had the energy of
Patrick Carpenter's hat tonight you're
very cool I'm not sure who that is
that's the last guy that was just up
here where have you been dude yeah yeah
I can't remember his name so I'm [ __ ]
with that I know you're very very cool
can you remember oh
he's not gonna try
he if you had her watch we could see
that your heart rate hasn't risen since
you got up here I appreciate that I'm
trying to remain calm yes that's the
most important thing it's just don't
lose your cool and fly off the handle
Drew I know thank you that's the fear of
yours yeah I'm a bit of a wild character
what's the craziest thing you've done on
a wild Bender uh I got arrested three
times in the course of six months Lexi
you dodged a bullet okay [ __ ] it I know
all right maybe there's hope maybe
there's potential
[Music]
um I'm really into alcoholics and drug
addicts that have criminal records so
like that's my type would you be willing
to give up running for a bit for this
bad boy here
it's tough that's tough how do you think
I have to deal with it I have to
have to somehow
still gotta run away absolutely
like basically I'm crazy so like
I wouldn't say that's obvious I enjoy
running
she did start the date out by saying oh
no
is that usually how your dates start out
most of the time no what the what's a
typical date for you
um
that's a good question
I like you
typical dates for me
um
well I haven't dated in a while so I
guess the last time I was dating it was
just like food and like cooking up so it
probably took so long to get to that
answer oh my God
food and hooking up yeah
you guys should try milking a steed I'm
just saying I'm saying clearly he's not
from Texas shut the [ __ ] up yeah cool
you're not wrong
you get food and you get to hook up with
the bowl well that's cool uh Michaela so
what's uh what's your favorite exercise
Core Power Yoga
Hans I don't know what gives you that
thought that inkling I do like yoga but
running is my favorite exercise
that's cool what are you running away
from you'd say all my problems such as
men men
specifically alcoholics but like it's
whatever
alcohol Enthusiast I mean
now have you dated any straight and
narrow guys and it just wasn't your
thing
you couldn't Bond over like uh movies or
Manchester by the sea or anything like
that
um I think my high school boyfriend was
like straight and narrow oh but [ __ ]
that guy right yeah
he still lives at home it's fine gay and
fat yeah I mean you're not wrong at all
have you ever dated women before no but
I'm open to it so like hell yeah I think
Drew is almost there
I'm getting there doggy yeah you got a
beautiful beautiful face just gotta grow
your hair out a little bit have you ever
[ __ ] a dude uh no no I I think I've
done straight for quite a while I think
I'm just gonna continue on this path uh
if it starts really tanking then maybe I
can mix it up but so far straight has
worked out what's the closest you've
been to tanking
to tanking going to the gay side brother
going dark what's the closest you've
ever gotten
um I take baths it's like yeah I think
taking baths that's pretty gay dude
that's pretty nice yeah bath salts or
masks yeah no with the bath bombs and
everything okay well that's why it's gay
yeah like yeah what are you getting
clean for a dude yeah I mean like I
couldn't explain that to my grandfather
like like yeah I just need to do it what
with bath one bath bombs oh I didn't
think they got this little pink little
cute thing that I put in a bath and like
then I like to hang out and read books
like it's it's fun
yeah they didn't have water back then
they just dry cleaned themselves
that's cool you took a bath so that's
pretty gay you think for sure books are
very gay too I mean for sure what book
are you reading uh the last one I read
was uh ordinary men uh that sounds gay
that sounds gay man it has been in the
title so that already sounds yeah were
there is it a picture book showing
ordinary men doing oh no I know how to
read pretty well
um and so it was a World War II uh kind
of like docu history type busy they're
perfect for each other she won't stop
bragging about running he won't stop
we're bragging about reading
maybe you guys could run and read at the
same time at least he knows how to read
yeah not like that guy from Alabama hey
Jimmy can we get the white lights up
here the instead of the blue it's white
as possible White is my favorite color
same same yeah just to match all the
other people on the stage right now
thank you Hans
Michaela how do you uh how do you like
dating in Austin is that a thing that
you do
um it kinda is a thing I do I've been
single for like four days so four days
congratulations yeah thank you were
there any drops left in that shot glass
buddy that you went back for I think you
have a problem
uh just an enthusiasm
have you heard of sober October Hans I
think you could tell this guy a lot yeah
yeah I heard you got some rich friends
recently
recently been having rich friends
um but yeah that's cool you're uh
sipping that shot yeah I would like
another one but I don't think I have the
pull to like get people to have the pole
to order a shot at a bar
um to do it from the stage I think that
would probably be more apparently well
just do it afterwards yeah that's are
you trying to mooch a free shot out of
Hans not a chance in hell let me just
get Joe Rogan to buy you a shot right
now oh no oh you have rich friends Hans
you can get me a shot right
oh no definitely could I just choose not
yeah you're fantastic at math but like I
just want to like you know just get it
afterwards that's over the line you
don't say don't tell me that I'm good at
math you [ __ ] hillbilly cause and
[ __ ] it you're better at it than I am
bad dancing white crack ass [ __ ]
spot on with all those you're spotting
with all those that's that's probably
true Drew uh Drew what's like the
whitest thing that you've done recently
yellow
um
it would be easier for me to grab that's
cool
uh Michaela what's uh what what do you
think about the white men do you have
you dated mostly white men or
unfortunately I've dated mostly white
men it's a real disappointment that's
the worst it really is what have you
noticed about white men
um
they're just boring
they don't do culture they don't do
enough drugs for you hey bath bombs and
books are our culture okay all the white
guys I've dated do drugs to like that's
probably why they're really boring yeah
nothing like a boring old drug addict
sitting there doing drugs that's the
most exciting thing about them is the
fact they've been to rehab a few times
in jail how many times have you done
drugs
enough
enough are you on drugs right now
unfortunately no this would be a lot
more bearable if I was whoa hey what the
[ __ ] I thought I was killing it up here
y'all are great y'all are oh thank God I
didn't realize that was that old
foreign
what drug would you like to do with
Michaela
[Music]
Joy blow yeah for sure the fentanyl [ __ ]
ruined that so like we gotta get like a
tester kit or something oh safe drive
but uh I got Narcan I'll let you do it
first yeah for sure uh I prefer you did
it first
um but I can get a at least know how to
use Gnar candy you know but uh what a
gentleman I got some ladies ladies first
sounds like an exciting second day I
mean wow
sounds like an episode of intervention
this is very mean on the straight narrow
that's awesome what were you doing
before cocaine
oh the other stuff
heroin uh once turns out it's [ __ ]
awesome
uh I understand why people do it a bunch
so I was just like oh [ __ ] if I do this
I'm just gonna keep doing this all the
time so just once and done with that one
how'd you do it bro uh uh I pansied out
I just smoked it I'm terrified of
needles I faint every [ __ ] time
so you're not vaccinated oh yeah no
[ __ ] way dude
how many times have you had covered uh I
think twice hell yeah and how about you
no times because I'm vaccinated you
didn't get covered I haven't got covered
yet and you had your vaccinated and
boosted what an Odd Couple we have here
we're not a couple
[Laughter]
Michaela doesn't want to date a trump
supporter I have a sneaking suspicion we
might disagree on politics oh very much
though bring that uh bring that Bernie
guy back up here he sounds great
I'm a Bernie guy the guy with two broken
arms
oh he's a nice fella I met him out back
he's a nice guy yeah it's easy to find
the veins on him he just got stationary
arms he doesn't move around that much
yeah he's a he's a nice guy oh you know
him uh just met him out back he's he
seemed like a very nice fella would you
call him an ordinary man
uh I mean other than like the whole like
not being able to use his arms part yeah
hey he said he can use it a little to
drive well no like I offered to sign up
for him because he had like you know
like his [ __ ] up arms and [ __ ] and I
was like hey man like I can sign up for
you and like but like you know the same
way handicapped people feel like they
need to like do it themselves
yeah I was just like dude I can just
write down your name on a piece of paper
I know how are you sure you weren't
hitting on him
um I feel like like I said I think I'm
still sticking with the straight thing
I'll let you know if it changes yeah
denial of like a map you're one of my
first uh candidates uh but yeah okay
thank you I am not flattered at all
that's awesome it's just in denial it's
fine he'll come out eventually yeah we
eventually do a straight man we always
do
that's a good pickup line oh I I think
it might be hard for you to jerk off by
yourself you want with some help with
that yeah
solid yeah solid pulling yeah how about
Alabama reach-around
but uh Michaela how's uh how's your
dating life you uh recently broke up
four days ago uh what kind of drugs was
that guy on uh uh cocaine ketamine
benzos
[Music]
um why did you break up with him
um
he got sober
um what are you doing here it sounds
like you should just take a walk down
6th Street and find your next guy she's
here to go to the arch and find her next
book yeah there's like seven dudes
walking around back there that you would
love I would love to introduce you
you're in the right place this is a
buyer's market right here I just go to a
meetings to meet my next man it's fine
hell yeah that's the alarm that's the
new cocaine alarm
Drew uh what do you think about uh doing
drugs with your date have you ever done
that before
uh yes I I've been a drug user since I
found out drugs existed
nice so seven
yeah like well nine for alcohol but you
were drinking alcohol at night what
trailer park did you grow up in uh
actually a gated community
gated community privilege that's always
the worst that's where it happens yep uh
yeah no uh so yeah we found out that uh
my buddy's dad uh threw beer in the
fridge and I was just like what the [ __ ]
does alcohol do
so we went and got that yeah turns out
one and a half beers at nine [ __ ] you
up and then I was like oh that's an
awesome feeling but it makes you feel
sick after so I didn't like that so I
just found out about pot right pot's
nice and easy how old were you when you
did that nine and a half okay yeah 12
and then just maintain that for a while
and then uh about 18 found out like oh
even if you're sick it still turns out
that's a pretty [ __ ] fun feeling so
just ride it out yeah and that's
so usually where Michaela comes in
yeah and now she can find me at a
meeting now you're at 19. so
congratulations I appreciate it but I'm
approaching 30. no way you're 30 years
old yeah we both got the baby face doggy
okay
doggy you don't know him like that dude
I can tell you're going to skank Fest
next week yeah that was the reference I
was trying to make yeah I appreciate
that that's cool you're almost 30.
Michaela would you date a guy that's
almost dead
he's 30. I mean I don't think the age is
going to kill him but probably his
lifestyle will kill him first those bath
bombs
definitely the bath salts I don't I
think he looks like the types of new
baths you like to do bath bombs and get
some pop-ups I have accidentally done
bath salts okay how do you accidentally
do Bow salt because you do Mystery drugs
at concerts people just hand you powders
yeah you know and they're just like hey
and like how many times have you
overdosed
not enough but like you know like it's a
nice gesture people trying to mean
they're trying to say nice things
they're trying to say here here's a gift
for you so like you just be polite and
you just take them and you don't ask a
lot of questions yeah you don't want to
be a dick yeah right just refusing white
powders for no reason
that's such a faux pas yeah I mean it's
just rude when you're doing random white
powders remember pinky out sure left
left left pinky that's where you put
your Signet ring okay so uh Drew what's
uh what's your favorite thing to do on a
date
um oh I'm actually quite good at this
uh so simple uh Simple Thing Michaela
does not believe you uh oh for sure
you're right to not believe me
um but uh make some kind of instance
where I make a fool out of myself that
kind of like drops uh you know like
drops a thing I agree
um and then do something that's just a
little bit that's a memory right if we
go out to a restaurant that's maybe not
like the normal restaurant you would go
to it's not just a nice steakhouse
um we go to somewhere that we can try
something new right we can try some kind
of sushi that we've never tried before
then we share a new experience together
we can experience that new thing that
you do on a date is do try sushi
new [ __ ] is the point whoa dude let me
write this down
Sushi no just just new [ __ ] the idea is
like [ __ ] do something new that makes a
memory and then that way they remember
you and it seems to work out quite well
for me awesome that's fun that's why you
do white powders at concerts oh no no
that's because let's make a memory
tonight yeah it's really important he
makes memories now because he's lost so
many over the years yeah sure I was here
last week and I got a fat green bruise
on my ass and I don't remember how I got
that oh why don't you show us yeah let
us see let's see yeah yeah for sure
laughs
well be careful because this is on
YouTube right so let's uh
uh hold on I need to shine a flashlight
on this bad boy I mean it's kind of
green I wouldn't brag about it
I mean I've seen Greener dude I don't
know
I guess bring that nurse chick back up
here Nicole
Nicole we got some lumps and bruises for
you baby
Nicole can you throw this in the
background I don't think she gets paid
enough for that
what do you do Michaela I'm a glorified
secretary
nice who glorifies it no one
I work in sales support so I like I just
help sales agents
do drugs really I mean
I bet a lot of sales agents do do drugs
that's your future 100 okay 100
that's the only way they can function
that well
there's no way what does your company
sell
aftermarket car warranty so they
definitely do drugs oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
ban her ban her from the venue what the
hell I've blocked you [ __ ] so
many times on my phone I'm pissed
that's actually my company that is but
like my company doesn't actually call
you we don't do outbound sales I take it
all back I take it off unethical
aftermarket car warranty yeah we're
slightly ethical our parent companies
from Canada so we're obviously great
nice that sounds like a great way to
find new drugs is work at an aftermarket
car warranty company
um that's cool what do you do Drew Drew
uh I just moved down to Austin two and a
half weeks ago so at the moment I'm
unemployed but previously I installed uh
the fire suppression systems I work in
construction that's when you made the
clap about construction workers that
would be me I I said what I said when I
said construction workers freak me out I
still mean it that's fair that's fair
for sure
that's cool yeah I definitely stick out
being a skinny as [ __ ] white guy but uh
I mean the meth will do that too hey I'm
a classy drug user I don't okay cocaine
cocaine will do that to you too okay
that makes more sense well I hope you
didn't put any drugs in your fire
suppressant system because that seems
like a great way to dose everyone oh no
that would actually be awesome you're on
fire and then at least oh [ __ ] because
you're on fire at least you're high yeah
if you're gonna die you might as well be
on cocaine the best time to be high
uh Drew so uh what would where would you
go with Michaela what do you think that
she would like to do
uh I'm seeing tats she likes running
uh I'm guessing you want to get a tattoo
while you're running no uh how do you
feel about meow wolf you've been you've
been there yet
no okay it's a really cool art gallery
where they got uh it's very like
psychedelic art they got Sushi there uh
no sushi there's no food it's an art
gallery
and just like uh it's a very nice art
gallery it's very psychedelic and you
can do it it's kind of like stepping
into Alice in Wonderland and so like you
like can open like the door and it's a
really fun experience
okay wow
wow
the hard cell uh that's cool so you take
her out of Austin you'd go on a road
trip to Las Vegas or something I know
San Antonio is the most uh known
location for uh you want to go to San
Antonio with this man you just met oh
I'm dating a Puerto Rican she'll [ __ ]
stab me
well that was gonna be a hard pass
luckily you're on YouTube right now oh
she's gonna be pissed and fired up when
she sees this dude probably I don't know
if they know how to work YouTube but if
she can figure it out
she will be yeah they don't have YouTube
in Puerto Rico right now because they
don't have power oh no she's at work but
yeah just kidding I think they might
even have like a little like uh
translate language app
okay it's so he got a girl who can't
speak English that's the only like way
you could get a girl at least he's not
dating an Asian woman
keep your dick out of our gene pool
but uh Drew Cregan and Michaela recently
went on a cragle recently one on a day
give it up for them thank you for coming
on the date Michaela and Drew
okay
nice to meet you guys thank you nice to
meet you drew please don't hurt anyone
tonight
cute little shot glass we got James
Bower oh man
okay where's James Bauer here he comes
from the back whoo James get on up here
are you ready to fall in love with
Adriana
Adriana a late bucket Edition hell yeah
if any of you are thirsty there might be
another drop or two left in that shot
glass so maybe uh knock that [ __ ] back
oh
pulling out the chair
[Applause]
that was hot how we doing I'm good how
are you amazing how was your name is
James I'm Adriana well that's a
beautiful name thank you it's a very
common Hispanic name James is the most
common name in the world but it's
translated to every it's a Biblical name
so it's actually Sheamus and it's
Jacques and it's Jaime
so I can be anything you want
[Laughter]
so you know
you know we'll see about that so is your
day it was amazing I woke up and uh went
to the head shop and got like 80
whippets
and then a head shop yeah what's that
head shop it's a smoke shop
we have those in Texas even the weeds
like you know illegal we still have a
bunch of [ __ ] you can get [ __ ] up on
that's way worse than weed and they're
called whippets
and they're great when you're on
mushrooms just so you know
so I did that and watched uh the The
Dark Crystal the new one
yeah I watched a new one today and then
is that anime no it's actually like Jim
Henson Muppets which is really cool is
that so they do like yeah it is okay and
time give it up for Adriana and James
so how was your day uh I just went to
the pool I read a book hey [ __ ]
time's up time's up
oh God that date was going so well until
it wasn't
James is really uh uh you know Purpose
Driven he has a goal he's going to
accomplish it
that's awesome man a guy that's actually
trying to get laid on this show what a
what a concept I I wasn't expecting it
you know Mr THC invited me so I'm just
you know I'm here for the fun hell yeah
that's a good attitude it's the kind of
attitude you get when you do a lot of
whippets yeah it was really hot when he
pulled her chair out and then a little
less hot when you were talking about
banging like 100 whippets or whatever
like what holy [ __ ] crystals so I mean
you know
she wasn't Hocus Pocus got it got it you
were talking about how your name uh
translated it into a bunch of different
languages one of them was Jaime Jaime
you've broken a lot of Jaime's in your
day
um just one in my mom's Volvo that my
brother now owns wait is Jaime vulva or
Volvo what are you saying brother what
the [ __ ] exactly broke your mom's hymen
no it was in her car that's a sick brag
it was you know it was a weird place too
let me tell you I've milked a lot of
steeds but I've never broken my mom's
hymen in the back of her car okay I am
from Brownsville Texas okay I'm
originally from Austin but you know
Brownsville is pretty cool if you like
driving through it
is
[Laughter]
do you want to defend your hometown I
was giving you a chance I I love where
I'm from it's so ethnic it's on the
coast I mean I don't live there anymore
but I loved it yeah it's great not a lot
of whippets over there
there's a lot of drugs
never mind it sucks
James uh What uh what do you think about
Arlington is that where you're from I'm
from Austin originally oh Austin I'm
from Austin uh I lived here for so long
yeah you look like you're from Austin
and then I lived in Louisiana like bro
bridge for a while and then Johnson City
you look like an Austin mascot this is a
old Austin
thank you you look like you got here on
two bird scooters
I I I have crashed on a bird scooter one
time and then I didn't drive one again
do you people not know how to use bird
scooters they're pretty goddamn simple I
was leaving crowbar actually that just
burned down
but I was leaving crowbar and I was
driving and this guy in a white truck
just slammed into me with his lights off
and then I was on the ground and I
looked up and as soon as I looked up
they saw that I was alive and they
peeled out as fast as they could they
were like oh dude well that was nice
that they stuck around let's go let's go
let's go down this guy has the last time
I was on a bird okay did this guy have
two broken arms by chance ooh he might
have been from Alabama
that's a good that's a good assumption
right there I knew that guy couldn't
drive
Adriana yeah are you
James is really focused James has a
mission uh Adriana have you ever dated
like a crust punk you know cyber
cyber criminal no no I haven't really
you don't know what you're missing yeah
you could get a lot of free whippets
you know Salt Lick Barbecue we can go to
matzo Rancho if you want to you know I
don't live in Austin and so oh you live
in Brownsville still no I live in
Nashville
I'm just visiting oh what you what's
your history with Nashville what's going
on no she's just visiting me too and
you're sad now no no I'm I'm even
happier
well you don't look happy
well that means that she only has a
short time to experience all the cool
things that Austin has you know yeah and
you're not dragging it along like most
people from California that move here
and find out later that it's you know
boring okay well you never had a chance
anyways so it's nice that you thought
you did but Adriana what kind of people
do you normally date
I love
Asian men oh yeah
oh [ __ ] I think you and I should leave
dude I could do some great Parts this
Show's now over everyone leaves I love
pot time you know I take you the best
spots on in Austin
um I love older men who are wealthy
um
are you older Hans what's the age
difference here I know Joe Rogan
he's wealthy so okay you could date him
I guess yeah Hans has rich friends he
could probably even get you a shot
yeah I have it in at this bar where I
give them money and they give me drinks
it's just it's a special relationship we
have here
that's cool so you actually like Asian
men that I've never heard that before
yes
yes dark haired Asian men who are that's
all of them we all have this hair no my
last boyfriend
Asian so we get the blonde hair blue
eyes always
a white asian I've never heard that term
amazing
yeah oh no I've only ever heard a wink
but I don't I don't said he was a waging
equation that's beautiful yeah it sounds
exotic I like the dark the dark-haired
ones his penis was really small his
penis came over you like oh wait
laughs
oh God James
got away with words this guy I do
voiceovers as well really for the radio
for Austin Texas what's the most
distinct voice that's most different
from yours that you can do Texas are you
ready to come back outside Soul Food
Truck Fest return that's good that kind
of sounds like you though okay
the boys for Juneteenth for uh soul food
trucks
okay this is uh I'm nervous
voice
I was at a place called whip my soul up
north and I walked in asked him for
chicken and waffles and the people
behind me in line they're like man you
have a great voice can you add some soul
to your voice I was like why yes I can
that's the same voice exactly I just use
the same voice so you just have one
voice you have like a monster truck
rally voice around Austin you do
commercials for you're stealing voice
over jobs from black man what the hell
whoa hey only my wife friends have
problems with all my black friends are
like dude I'm so proud of you man like
you're my boy like that's some [ __ ] man
all two of you all my white friends are
like why do they have a white guy doing
it
um see now you feel uncomfortable yeah
you really called me out man hey [ __ ]
James you uh got a lot of confidence
that's wonderful uh keep it up Adriana
what uh what do you do for work I'm
High School science teacher okay nice
and uh
and how uncomfortable do the high school
students get around you um
yeah a lot of them wouldn't get up after
this class was over and they're like oh
I'm just gonna sit here for a while
thanks for that addition their oasian
you you have a lot of connections with
middle schoolers or I mean just the
Hawaiian ones where do you think he gets
his whippets from exactly they have the
best ones because they go to the dentist
the most
James uh what other drugs do you do
you know like the legal ones totally
just all the legal ones you never smoked
heroin or no no actually if it doesn't
name mean it's probably not for me I'm
like mean things like had a mean
methamphetamine if it grows I said
heroin dude if it grows on the ground
probably no one was talking about I
didn't say heroin mean or whatever the
[ __ ] you just I said you know if it
grows on the ground it's probably okay
so you don't do ketamine no you don't do
Dramamine
with my dad yesterday and I felt very
good about myself so yeah that's where
you got your Juneteenth voice from
exactly
that and growing up in broadbridge
Louisiana
much like Brownsville but not really at
all
it's just because you drive through
Brownsville again you're freaking her
out dude uh I got a question for you uh
what's what what are you teaching right
now in science what's the lesson right
now um I'm an environmental science
teacher so kind of like biomes
I love those things yeah who doesn't
love a good bio [ __ ] man I love it
I want to smoke some biome right now not
till November
that's cool what's your what what so
there's different biomes like arboreal
forests
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] you just made ooh
[Laughter]
James you can go yeah
no that's cool also deserts yeah yeah
Hans oh my God I know a lot about bio
holy [ __ ] I actually did grow up on a
zoo out in Johnson City what the [ __ ]
you're wasting your time dude you're
[ __ ] blocking right now I know a lot of
I know this is how you talk game you
talk about biomes okay this guy knows
what's up what do you know about biomes
that's cool nothing he's not even paying
attention
what's your favorite biome James
giraffes
because they got the giraffe tongue
wraps around hell yeah so Savannah
he doesn't want to talk about dude you'd
get an F yeah bro take your brain don't
worry about this so we so how you doing
[Laughter]
James you're doing great we all respect
you well thank you all very much this is
actually my second time on stage so
thank you very much nice that was the
first time
um my first time was a week ago when he
snuck onto a middle school play to buy
some whippets from one of the actors
yeah hey guys hey I'm looking for
whippets tonight that's right what's
you guys are in the middle of something
I'll get out of your hair real quick
but no man this was very cool all right
well give it up for it James and Adriana
they went on a date together
thank you James hell yeah hell yeah
we got time for one more date oh no
I don't want it to end we got a lot of
names in here I hope we pull one [ __ ]
normal guy like Jesus Christ dude all
the women have been normal yeah ladies
you're killing it okay I've been on
whippets uh Jose
nicknamed roro I mean it's all the same
ladies Jose
roro coming on up hmm
uh do you want it to be random or did
you like any lady more than more than
the others Hans because it's the same
three now let's just because I know
yeah there's a lot of Michaela's in the
boat there's more than two michaelas
we've already done two michaelas
everyone's named Michaela here oh [ __ ]
Michaela C is that someone okay all
right gray come on up here for Nicole we
did it and Michaela's very excited Kayla
this has been a Michaela full episode
that's crazy
it was great oh I am
that's great stood up for her like she
was a American flag
give it up for Michaela
Michaela and roro starting now
Michaela is that yeah roro okay
yeah like that exactly um where are you
from Arkansas Arkansas yeah where are
you from Meet Peru
South America okay yeah I'm really good
with geography it's very easy actually
it was just like outside the border
Mexico light never been to Mexico I went
to a passport
oh nice where are you going around the
country
where do you want to go
you're my passport
do you have like a special location that
you want to travel to go to Mexico
Mexico
nice
like going to the pyramids or are you
going to go like partying or just oh
he's at the beach
know I really thought the forehead fair
enough well you've got two weeks so nice
11 weeks yeah whatever yep where's your
favorite place you've been
um Rome
oh that would be really cool I think the
Lizzie McGuire Movie isn't real right
I've never watched it
yeah yeah absolutely 100
I don't know so what do you do for work
oh
how I'm 33. you're 33 yes what do you do
for what
um I'm in commercial real estate nice
and what do you do there I'm a
transaction manager for who
Christian and Wakefield oh nice and time
give it up for Michaela and roro
Michaela is there are there a lot of
Michaela's in commercial real estate I
definitely not is that like and what are
your thoughts on master bedroom versus
primary bedroom or that's not a
commercial real estate oh [ __ ] right
come on so uh what's the what's it going
right on Office Buildings at the moment
biscuit how what's the going rate for an
office building at the moment it depends
on I guess where here I work more in
retail commercial real estate okay yeah
shopping center like uh like something
that yeah if you're gonna sell let's say
Peruvian cocaine
I mean I've seen stuff at like 107
square foot are you looking to get into
are you looking to buy a piece of what's
your business dude that's what I used to
do in Australia I used to be in
development you used to bother real
estate agents about their prices all the
time yeah wow
no I was I I was born in Peru moved to
Australia to University and worked
accent I got it yeah stupid yeah no it's
cool I like it oh thanks yeah
um your accent is also very very good
well you have an American accent well
for me this is America Peru oh sorry
it's not your bus attack my bad hands
you're right well it is Asian man I know
um so oh well oh hey he's Asian enough
for Adriana and that's all that matters
okay that's the only real love 's coming
out of town okay yeah
the poor Asians are you sure about that
she said that she wanted someone with a
job like the brown Nations I mean sorry
sorry yeah I'm not as white as the
cocaine that you sell
uh I do marijuana and mushrooms so
things that are harmless I used to do a
little cocaine when I was in real estate
and but I had to stop it was really bad
for me think I've had to do cocaine but
yeah but you're a female so you're a
female so you're unicorns right like
there's so many of you them well in the
math the population in America I mean
like in real estate in commercial real
estate is very like I think that in
America in general when I've seen for
what I've seen in corporate world it's
very much so male driven right I would
say so yeah perfect so because the whole
team is the same in Australia because
that's what I was that's I'm referring
to the same markets right so because of
that you're a unicorn you're a unicorn
in your field and that's where the
questions that I was asking perfect
nice now that you know that what are you
gonna sell
no I was asking how much it is because
I'm interested because it's something
that I'm interested in yeah what are you
going to do with that I would use like
co-star like
some good yeah that'll be good yeah
absolutely
okay well you got some guitar picks on
your ear are you into music guitar picks
yeah their hearts
uh yeah Hans yeah you [ __ ] more
you know what
you're like the smartest looking dude at
the strip club hold on ladies
blind
oh that's unfortunate very really good
Vision but
there you go good genetics good to know
absolutely is that why you haven't seen
the Lizzie McGuire Movie because you
can't really see it that well I'm 24.
what's going on there 24. oh really yeah
okay how old are you 33.
that's what my age range is set to on
hinge
he goes up to 33. you better work quick
roro you're about to age out
you're right on the customer dude come
on what are we doing here man like Jesus
I'm a bit sensitive about my age I'm
getting gray why no Gray's good is it
yeah oh thank you Jesus you just like
totally changed his world right now you
guys are never gonna see each other ever
again but he is totally embracing the
gray after tonight that's crazy yeah
uh
June 14th I share birthdays with Donald
Trump
and and Che Guevara [ __ ] you well my
birthday's on President's Day some years
so yeah yeah so you ever get a good
mattress for your birthday
no but I got out of school sometimes so
not as cool but okay hey I mean I guess
so what have you sold commercial real
estate for any cool businesses that we
know of um
yeah you can't tell me you can tell that
you can say no I mean I don't know like
the rules so I mean yes probably some
business you've heard of I've been on
their accounts yes okay like if you ever
order food
parade delivery service yes um one
specific one that may start with the D
they have conveniences now
training
doordash yeah doordash I was on that
account for a while um any head shops
that sell whippets
well someone needs to I mean whatever
what about medical senses no
no I don't like it's not even a drug and
like yeah Coke and meth and whatever the
hell they were talking about earlier
okay I mean no offense like do your
thing but like yeah do you boo but you
never wanted to like smoke a good heroin
and do a bath bomb and read a book
nothing like that sounds good
so what are you doing what are you doing
what do you do at concerts you just
listen politely you're turning down all
the mysterious powders in concerts okay
do you drink no drugs no marijuana
nothing no no marijuana idea yeah all
right mushrooms no no psychedelics
I don't think I like the idea of like
not being in control yeah I'm a very in
control person so come on you're a real
estate you're a woman I'm in control yes
we know yeah whoa I think that was some
Peruvian sexism
well I was I was raised by a very sexist
dad that was born in the 30s so
unfortunately you were born you got to
break the chain dude and I was raised
like a baby boomer at the time of
Millennials so I'm a bit racist but I'm
also a little bit not racist
like I
I'm Brown and proud I really hate myself
hold on a second joke it's a joke oh
okay I didn't get it you're Brown and
come on I'm not I'm not come on
things I do I do he's I know the
siblings and all the siblings much
better much better looking than me we
are Irish twins they call it he Irish
twins like less than 12 months 11 months
apart yeah that's so cool cool brother
20. yeah so four years but yeah and your
parents together were separated never
together never together separated yeah I
don't really know who my dad is all
right yeah yeah I knew my dad on 213. he
thought we were puppies you know he was
like yeah 13 years old good to go and he
just left obviously came back well
don't bring up warts Nicole's off duty
okay
there was a couple drops in there
plus some so I don't think there's
anything left yeah yeah they look like
water too I was like Jesus anyway it's
probably like rubblements or something
you look like a Roman sky all right
what's up
all right uh what's up with you guys
yeah it's uh that's fun yes got
questions or something I don't know yeah
uh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] pressure
what's your middle name or what's my
what middle name Michaela Christine
Elise cray I asked for one middle name
pick one are you Hispanic I am
why do I have so many names I don't know
my great grandma's named Christine and
my mom liked Elise so well luckily this
is all on the internet so now you got
about 17 stalkers follow me on Instagram
oh yeah oh and you're also in hinge
right like
yeah I'm on Facebook
she's on doordash I am banned from
Tinder are you bad boy roro shut the
[ __ ] up you talk too fast this isn't
Spanish
hey I talk fast too I understood
everything you said that's great there
were a couple times you were like huh
okay well I do keep up by telling him to
shut up uh uh that's cool roro what uh
what what uh what lovely romantic thing
can you say in Spanish to uh Michaela
[Music]
um
I've said that she was intelligent
good-looking woman that's thank you
started with intelligence how does that
make you feel Michaela it makes you feel
great I don't don't speak any Spanish so
neither do I not jokes what uh what do
you what what do you want to say to uh
roro in English maybe to match his
romantic Spanish
I think you should embrace your gray
hair because it looks great thank you
and also the glasses make you look smart
and I like your tattoos oh thank you
very much
well give it up for Michaela
that was the show thank you guys so much
for coming out wow Ike anything you uh
want to plug uh I guess you can follow
me on Instagram at icrafferty Ike
Rafferty Ike is on Instagram he's also
on kill Tony a lot so check him out
there sure yeah uh give it up for Ike
Rafferty the guest house for tonight hey
thanks guys you were great give it up
for yourselves good night thank you so
much good night
all right
[Music]